[Music]
andrew is with us in orlando hi andrew
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave and chris so excited to talk to
y'all thank you sure
how can we help so i'm 25 years old i
don't have any debt
i graduated college this past may and i
was able to live at home and do an
in-state school
and so i was able to save a lot during
those years
and right now i have about 3 500 in the
bank
and then i have a charles schwab account
that i just transferred about 38 000
into but it's not invested right now and
so i'm wondering
what y'all's thoughts are on what i
should should i do a lump
big sums of something into different
funds or
what's your idea and thoughts on that
now did you graduate yet
yes sir and i just started a new job
great
great and have you moved into your new
place
um well right now i'm actually still at
home
and i'm hoping i'm talking to a friend
of mine we had actually moved out
together but once coveted hit we moved
back in
to our house and so i'm looking with him
right now to move out
okay cool what do you do for a living
how much do you make
right now i make about 30 000 but that's
i'm working part-time
this new job i got i should be starting
full-time
in the next few weeks or the next month
or so
and then that should bring it up and
hopefully i'll get a pay raise in there
as well
where did the money in the charles
schwab account come from
it came i had it just in my savings
account i've been
just saving for years and then i just
kind of transferred it over
wanting to kind of get started on some
stuff all right and how's your car
what kind of car do you have um it's
it's paid off it's a
toyota okay and i don't so i don't have
any debt right now
okay and you plan to have this vehicle
for what another five
ten years yes sir okay so
it's in really good shape that's good
that is good
well i like the fact that you all are
planning to get back out on your own
you and a roommate um and so you know
with that in mind
beginning to look and giving yourself
some cushion if your car is stable
right and you're making 30 you're
getting ready to try to get to full time
you have some of that money you hold on
to for as part of your emergency fund
the rest of it i'm going to invest that
for the future buddy
yeah okay and or and or it's your first
home fund to either one whatever you
want to do with it
that's what i was thinking about too i
wasn't sure because i had originally
kept it in savings
but i didn't really have a purpose of
okay i'm saving up for this
and so i just started thinking it was
probably not super smart to just let it
sit there
that's that's good yeah i don't mind
that at all i would invest it
either into retirement accounts and roth
iras and so forth
and or i would put aside from the
emergency fund
and or i would just set aside invested
in a mutual fund for your first home
purchase and continue to add to it and
that's your down payment fund
and so now it's got a name it's got a
purpose and that's very smart for it to
have a purpose
that also tells you how to invest what
to invest it in
once you give it a name once you give it
a purpose